Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneur spirit.
And we're still blazing a trail
for those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
At Doughp, we serve
nostalgia by the scoop.
‐Whoo‐whoo!
‐We're here for the big kid
inside of all of us.
‐...by working smart...
[ Cuban laughs ]
It's hardly ideal
dipping conditions.
But not
with Saucemoto.
Narrator:
...by thinking big...
Bolos: We want your help
to bring DeskView
to every window
around the world.
Narrator:
...and chasing their dreams...
Where do your envision
your business going?
World cookie‐dough
domination.
‐Wow!
‐You're an amazing operator.
O'Leary: But I want
a little more equity.
I'll do it for 50%.
‐You've got to be careful.
Kevin is a vampire.
‐Silence, please.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is an innovation
for the modern office space.
♪♪
Hi, Shar‐‐
[ Loud, indistinct
talking ]
Hey! Can you guys
be quiet?
We're ‐‐ We're trying
to pitch to the Sharks ‐‐
Excuse me. One second.
[ Talking continues ]
Come on. Guys. Guys.
Woman: I cannot believe we are
having this discussion again!
All right.
[ Door clicks, no audio ]
Ah, that's better.
‐That's better. Try it again?
‐Try again?
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Anthony Pucci.
And I'm Nick Pucci. We're from
Los Angeles, California,
and we're seeking
$350,000
for 10% equity
in our company.
Sharks, it's probably
been some time
since you worked
in a cubicle
or even sat
in an open‐office desk.
But did you know
most offices today
feature
an open‐design plan?
While it's great for
collaboration and cutting costs,
most employees are less
productive because of it.
And that's because
employees are dissatisfied
with their
work environment.
In fact, a lack of sound
and visual privacy
is by far and away
the biggest strain
on employee morale.
Introducing Cubicall...
‐Ta‐da.
‐...the modern phone booth.
Cubicall is
the efficient solution
to the shortcomings of the
design of modern‐day offices.
Our booth focuses on the four
pillars of privacy needs ‐‐
audio, visual,
territorial,
and information.
So distractions
like these...
Whoo! Girl!
I know, I know, I know!
...become a thing
of the past.
[ Laughter ]
And our Cubicall booths
are fully customizable.
They can be finished
in a variety of colors,
materials,
and even custom graphics.
And those bifolding doors
allow Cubicall
to fit into offices where
every inch of space is critical.
So, Sharks,
invest in us...
So we can help employers
invest in their employees.
Which one of you
want to come down
and get a privacy break
from Mr. Wonderful
and test‐drive
one of the booths?
Greiner: I do!
‐Excuse me!
‐I want to try it.
‐All right.
‐Okay.
[ Indistinct conversations ]
Woman: No, we are not
doing this again!
[ Greiner laughs ]
♪♪
[ Knocks on glass ]
Oh, sorry. Excuse me.
Oh! Wow.
‐There you go.
‐All right.
It's ‐‐ It's really well
put together.
Were you saying anything
inside, Robert?
Yeah.
Oh, you can't hear
a thing in there.
‐Oh, you can hear.
‐Come on in. [ Laughs ]
Hey, what's
going on, guys?
How's it going?
What do we ‐‐
[ No audio ]
‐It's ‐‐ It works. It's quiet.
‐It really does.
[ Muffled screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
Can you guys
hear them?
‐Barely.
‐Barely. It really muffled.
O'Leary: It works.
Each booth comes with
an air‐circulation fan,
it comes a regular outlet
so you can plug in
a laptop and
two USB chargers.
Why don't you walk us
through the numbers?
So, we sell
the first one there,
which is
our Cubicall 2.
We sell it
for $6,995.
‐Whoa!
‐Expensive.
‐$6,000?
And what does it
cost you to make?
It costs us
$4,200 to make.
And how about
the big one?
The big one is $11,995.
‐[ Groans ]
‐Wow.
What was the cost
of the 11K one?
That one's $7,200.
‐Now, just ‐‐
‐Yeah, but wait a minute.
‐Relative, relative.
‐Yeah, the competition ‐‐
Our relative to that ‐‐
They're selling theirs
for about $15,000.
So, Nick, how did you
start the company? Tell us.
So, we started
our own marketing agency.
It was
an open‐plan office.
And it's a family
business, so ‐‐
We're Italian, so we talk
very excitedly ‐‐
‐What?!
‐Yeah. Come on!
And it just got the point
where any important calls
or any meetings
that we had,
we either had to leave
the office to take it...
Go in the stairwell.
...or we had to stay ‐‐
stay home.
I said, "We can't deal
with this anymore."
And after we put it in
our office, the clients came in
and they said, "Hey, can you
get me one of these?"
We said, "Yeah, sure."
‐Once you deliver it,
do you just simply
plug it in and it works?
‐Correct. Yeah.
‐Does it ship flat?
They do have to be assembled,
but as far as ‐‐
‐It ships flat.
‐We actually have a video,
if you guys want to see it.
‐Yeah, sure.
...quickly being assembled,
just a little time‐lapse.
‐Wow, you guys are fast!
‐Yeah, right?
‐It's with a little practice.
‐Yeah.
‐So, yeah, it ships flat.
It's super easy
to assemble.
Nick, have you sold
a bunch of them already?
Yes, we have.
We sold about 70 booths.
We sold ‐‐
So tell us your sales
the last 12 months.
Uh, last 12 months,
$495,000.
And when did you
start the business?
‐Last August.
‐How are you selling it?
Uh...
Strictly direct
to the end user online.
O'Leary: I like the solution,
but there's a huge problem here.
You're making $1,800
on the 6K version.
Your margins are so thin that
the only way this business works
is selling
direct to customers.
Yeah, but that's ‐‐
This is working for them.
Why would they
introduce all the ‐‐
Guys, it's not working.
You've only sold $495,000 ‐‐
They've been in business
for a year, Kevin.
‐Oh, my God. Doom, doom.
‐No, but how do you feel
about the margins?
Can you widen your margins?
‐We could.
‐We definitely can.
If we get the investment, able
to invest in the inventory,
we'd be able to add
another 20% to 30%.
What's the vision?
What's year two gonna look like?
I mean, we want to get
to $2.5 million next year.
That's about
300 booths.
And we think with an investment,
we can definitely do that.
‐Do you have competition?
‐Right now in the whole market,
there's probably about
four competitors
that we compete with.
Anthony:
Nobody does a bifold door.
It sounds trivial,
but you're putting these in
because space is an issue.
‐Okay, that makes sense.
Yeah, but you don't think
that a steel case
could come in and undercut
all of the parts of this
and bring the price
down by 50%?
I‐I think they could,
but they ‐‐
they won't hit these price
points at these margins.
I'd find that
hard to believe.
Look, congratulations on
what you've accomplished.
It's ‐‐ It's great,
obviously.
But I've got
a couple issues.
One ‐‐
it's capital‐intensive.
Two ‐‐ when you're just
getting started,
it's not unusual,
particularly for ‐‐
when you're cheaper,
to get orders direct online,
but I think you're gonna
have to go to some ‐‐
some other type of
two‐tier distribution.
That doesn't mean it won't be
a great business for you two.
It just means
it's harder to invest
and harder to get a return.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
But congratulations on
what you've accomplished.
Well, thank you.
Appreciate it.
‐You know, you're a niche
within a larger
furniture market.
I think this is a highly
competitive industry,
and I just don't know
how you're gonna break into it.
‐I'm out.
‐But ‐‐
Greiner: I totally get it.
My only problem is,
there are competition out there
that are already doing it,
and so I think I'm gonna
wait a really long time
for a return on my investment,
so, unfortunately, I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
We appreciate it.
Appreciate it.
I mean, just to sort of
paint the picture ‐‐
So, they do say that
80% of all offices
are open‐plan
offices now.
By estimates, there's maybe
about 9.1 million businesses,
you know, in the U. S.
If we were even
to sell one booth
to 0.1 of 1%
of those businesses ‐‐
Yeah. Everybody says that
about a big market.
We get it.
Guys, that's the kiss of death
on "Shark Tank."
When you say all you need
is 0.1 of 1%...
‐Yeah.
‐...that's never a good sign.
♪♪
I'm gonna make you an offer,
but it's commensurate
with the risk, okay?
I'll give you $350,000.
I want 10% of the company.
Here's how I get paid back.
Okay?
You realize they came in
asking for 10%.
‐I‐I'm not finished yet.
‐[ Laughs ]
Silence, please.
Every time you sell
one of these units,
I get $100.
After I recover $1,050,000,
which is three times on
my original investment,
it drops to $50
a unit forever.
Just what you want in
a low‐margin business.
It's commensurate
with the risk here.
Maybe Barbara
could do better.
Anthony, you got to be careful.
Kevin is a vampire.
He'll live forever.
[ Laughter ]
So $50 is gonna
last a long time.
Um, I have a lot of experience
with this, surprisingly.
Here's my offer.
It's better
than his, I think.
‐I don't think so.
‐His was so complicated.
I don't know what it meant.
‐Mine's pretty simple.
But I'm gonna give you
the $350,000
for 25% of the business.
‐Ouch!
‐Wait. Wait a minute.
‐Ouch.
That's much worse
than my offer ‐‐ much worse.
Are you kidding me?
Every dollar that comes in,
you get 100 bucks.
‐And you get triple‐paid.
‐Mine reduces over time, Mark.
Barbara's forever
25% of the company.
You know, Barbara ‐‐
Greiner: Your ‐‐ Yours reduces
to $50 over time.
That's
very expensive.
What do you
want to do?
‐What do you want to do?
‐Dude, oh.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Nick and Anthony have
two offers on the table,
from Kevin and Barbara,
for their office booth
company, Cubicall.
‐What do you want to do?
Dude, oh.
You might want
to go in a booth.
We can hear you.
[ Laughter ]
‐Go in your booth.
‐Should we? You want to go?
‐Yeah.
‐We'll go talk in the booth.
‐Ah!
‐Ah.
[ Door closes, Corcoran laughs ]
[ No audio ]
Greiner: This is hilarious.
They're using the calculator.
[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, Lord.
‐Welcome back, Nick and Anthony.
‐Oh, thank you.
Anthony: Did you guys hear us,
by any chance?
‐No.
‐Every word.
‐Okay.
‐What did you guys figure out?
So, Kevin, we really
appreciate your offer.
Yes.
Uh, it's a little too difficult
for me to figure out
and for the eventual sale
of the company. Um...
It's not a problem
when you sell the company,
'cause they just
buy out my royalty.
That's what happens.
In many of my companies
that's happened to.
‐For $1 billion.
‐Go on.
‐Still a little too complicated.
So, Barbara,
we would like
to counter with
$350,000 for 15%.
It's, uh, not enough,
I'm afraid.
I have to turn that down.
Yeah.
I expect to do a lot of heavy
lifting on this business,
and I have
tremendous contacts
in the contract
furniture space,
and I think I can make
the right introductions for you.
You can't budge
on the equity at all?
Uh, no, because I want
to be excited about it.
‐What do you want to do?
‐How about ‐‐ Could we do
$450,000 for 20%?
No, I really feel like
I need that quarter slice
to get really juiced up
about it.
O'Leary: Maybe you should
revisit my offer,
'cause it has merit,
actually.
You should
think about it.
It doesn't sound like
she's gonna budge.
Anthony, I don't think
these guys are budging.
What are you guys
gonna do?
What do you
want to do?
♪♪
Yeah.
Okay.
Barbara...
we'd like
to take the deal.
Terrific. Good move.
[ Applause ]
Corcoran: Good move.
It's a good deal
for everybody.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Thank you.
‐So much. Appreciate it.
‐My pleasure.
‐Thanks again.
‐Congrats, guys.
Nick: I think we got
a great Shark in Barbara.
With her contacts,
I think it's gonna do wonders
for our business.
I could see her point with
the risk, but I think it's ‐‐
I think we're gonna
do great with it.
♪♪
Narrator:
Earlier this season,
Kaley, Christian,
and Keira Young
came to the Tank with
their late dad's
innovative cutting board,
the Cup Board Pro.
Kaley: It was his dream
to pitch it on "Shark Tank."
As he was getting
his first prototype,
God called my mom home,
and then my dad was diagnosed
with 9/11‐related cancer
from being a fireman there.
They made a deal
with all five Sharks.
Let's see
how they're doing now.
After "Shark Tank,"
the amount of outpouring love
and support from
all over the world
was just
absolutely incredible.
We sold out of
all of our dad's inventory
within minutes of airing
on the East Coast.
We received 100,000 e‐mails
from customers trying to order
our dad's Cup Board Pro.
But we couldn't
take the orders
because we didn't
have inventory.
That's when
the Sharks stepped in
and introduced us
to Williams‐Sonoma.
Foss: Hi. Welcome
John: Williams‐Sonoma agreed
to a great licensing deal.
They're re‐engineering
the product,
they're manufacturing it,
and they're gonna be
distributing
throughout
the Williams‐Sonoma chains.
Kaley: The best part
of the deal is that
we get to buy
the Cup Board Pros
directly
from the manufacturer
and sell it directly to the
consumers from our websites.
We just got
our prototypes in.
‐These are beautiful.
‐It looks a lot lighter, right?
‐Yeah, it is.
‐You could store three of these
for one of the old version,
so great improvement.
They made it even better.
It is the best cutting board
I've ever seen,
and I think their business
is going to become huge.
Our dad would be
really happy with this.
Kaley: After "Shark Tank,"
we received thousands of e‐mails
from people wanting to help
firefighters, just like our dad.
Keira: So we set up a website
to accept donations,
and we received
over $41,000.
♪♪
Sudnik: We saw a chance
to make a dream come true
for a family that
has endured far too much.
Cuban: We're here to support
the Young family today
in remembrance
of their father.
Herjavec: It's so hard
to just imagine what it's like
to lose both parents
and then basically be left
to take care of yourselves.
I know we all feel honored
that we get to take a part
in their lives.
The way it's working out,
they will never have to work
for anybody else again,
and that was what
their dad's dream was.
As hard as goodbye has been,
the three of us are
so incredibly grateful
to be able to call
Keith Young our dad
and Beth Young our mom.
I would like to ask the Sharks
to please join me
and my siblings
as we present a check for
$41,100 to the FDNY Foundation.
Thank you.
O'Leary:
We've never had a deal like
this on "Shark Tank" before.
The power behind this
is the fact that everybody
wants to give back.
It's wonderful.
Cuban: This is such
a special place.
You guys did
an incredible job.
I know your dad
is looking down smiling.
Keira: The three of us
have come together
and we're stronger than ever
because of this experience.
Kaley:
We're super grateful to be able
to continue our dad's dream
and to just share our story with
more people all over the world.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a business that
indulges in a guilty pleasure.
♪♪
What's up, Sharks?
I'm Kelsey,
founder and fearless leader
at Doughp Cookie Dough.
I'm seeking $450,000
in exchange for 10%
of my company.
I'm Dallas‐born,
California‐raised...
Yeah.
...and I'm loving life
in the Bay Area,
running San Francisco's
first ever cookie dough bar.
‐Wow.
‐Life is crazy,
and adulting is hard.
But what if just
for a few moments,
you could be transported
back to your childhood,
sneaking bites of cookie dough
in the kitchen?
At Doughp, we serve
nostalgia by the scoop.
We're here for the big kid
inside of all of us.
However, we're anything
but childish.
We're a millennial brand
serving over 20,000
customers each month.
Well, I'm on a mission to get
Doughp in every city in America
through opening additional
high‐traffic storefronts,
franchising, and expanding
onto grocery‐store shelves.
Sharks, this deal is
too "Doughp" to pass up.
[dope]
Who's in?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐We get samples?
‐You want to try it first?
All right. [ Laughs ]
I've got some samples for you.
‐Please.
‐Do people love cookie dough?
‐Got the mouths watering.
‐Well, people that like sweets.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh.
I'm so stoked for
you guys to try this.
We've got
six different flavors.
There's one plate for you.
‐Thank you.
Here you go, Lori.
I've got a special for you guys.
I made a vegan avocado
brownie cookie dough.
Oh.
‐Thank you.
‐Cute names...
‐Thanks so much.
‐...Avoca‐dough.
‐Avoca‐dough.
‐[ Laughs ]
People love the puns.
‐I love the name.
Got to keep them
laughing.
Wow, it's sweet.
‐Thank you so much.
‐You bet.
‐It's really sweet.
‐Thank you so much.
Thank you.
So, we've got The O. G.
That's gonna be
your classic cookie chip.
The Vegan O. G. is made
with vegan butter,
so those on dietary
restrictions can indulge.
Cinnamood is gonna be
like a snickerdoodle
with white chocolate chips.
Raisin' The Roof is
an oatmeal‐raisin flavor.
What? What?
He's got it.
‐What, what?!
‐I see you.
Chocoholic is for
the chocolate lovers.
And then
This S'more is Hella Doughp.
So that's gonna be marshmallows,
graham crackers,
and chocolate chips,
just like a campsite.
Love the names.
Uh, our three sizes ‐‐
Self Control, Legit,
or Fully Commit.
Um...
‐Funny names.
So, we've got a storefront
on PIER 39.
Um, it's one of San Francisco's
biggest tourist attractions.
I know it well.
So, is that your only location?
Uh, that's our only
physical brick‐and‐mortar.
‐Is that the actual store?
‐Can I, um ‐‐
It is. Yeah.
We do $1,100 per square foot.
‐Ooh.
‐Wow, that's a lot.
‐Wow.
Do you have
competitors?
Yeah, there are
some competing companies.
So, there's one
in New York City,
uh, who's, uh,
sort of on par with me.
It's definitely coming in,
like the cupcake trend
and all that stuff,
where it's gonna take off.
O'Leary: Really?
Kelsey, when did you
start the business?
So, I started
in April of 2017.
Um, I had spent
10 years in tech.
I got moved ‐‐
‐Oh, I see the correlation now.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, right? Processor chips
to chocolate chips.
I had been working since
I was 16, uh, at Intel, and ‐‐
‐At Intel?
‐Yeah.
‐Since you're 16?
‐Yeah. So...
Why is that?
Uh, I started as
a high‐school intern,
but it was really hard on me,
and I put a lot
of pressure on myself,
so I developed a really
unhealthy relationship
with alcohol
through the years...
Oh.
...and Friday,
I turn three years sober.
‐Congratulations.
Um, so got sober, and that
changed my life entirely.
Uh, I've always had
this entrepreneurial bug,
and doing something
on your own
has just been
the most rewarding thing.
So in a year and a half,
we're over $850,000 in sales,
and I've got plans to ‐‐
‐Wow.
Wait, what are you making
on the $850,000?
Yeah, we have
a 35% net income ratio.
‐Okay.
‐Wow, that's great.
‐Um, we've got 14% this year ‐‐
‐This calendar year,
what will your income be
pre‐tax?
Our net income's $240,000
for this year so far.
Oh, there you go.
And what's your plan
going forward?
Where do you envision
your business going?
World cookie‐dough
domination.
Of course.
[ Laughter ]
How are you
gonna get there?
Um, my main focus
is on these high‐traffic
storefronts.
I'm in lease negotiations
right now
for a spot
on the Las Vegas Strip,
and the mall sees 72,000 people
per day enter their doors.
Wow.
So, you're here
on "Shark Tank" today
at a $4.5 million
valuation...
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐...and you're asking me to pay
30 times
your pre‐tax profits,
30 multiple
on something
that's completely
not proprietary,
because
it's cookie dough.
‐Yeah.
‐Anybody can do it.
The difference is,
you're a good operator.
Yeah.
Isn't that what always
makes the difference?
No, but it's not
worth 37 times.
It's just cookie dough.
Here's the problem ‐‐
you're gonna grow
until somebody says,
"I want to compete with you,
'cause it looks so good."
‐And then ‐‐
‐But she has competitors.
Yeah, there's certainly
a lot of competition,
and look at what happened
in cupcakes.
I'd like to compare myself to
one of the major cupcake brands
that made it through this ‐‐
with Sprinkles.
If you recall kind of
this rise,
every mom‐and‐pop
opening one on every corner.
But there are a few brands
we all know and love
still from
the cupcake trend.
I'm gonna be one of those
for cookie dough.
We're also expanding
into wholesale,
so looking
at grocery stores.
You've got major chains,
like Whole Foods.
‐Do you have any wholesale now?
‐Um, yeah.
So, these jars are just
starting to hit the market,
and we're in
San Francisco's airport.
Herjavec: Kelsey,
you're an amazing operator.
‐Oh, thank you very much.
‐Like, your story,
your numbers ‐‐
everything.
I don't like
cookie dough.
[ Mimics crying ]
Just kidding. [ Laughs ]
‐I know. I'm sorry.
But how many people
like cookie dough?
I would say
a significant amount.
How many people don't like
cookie dough?
I call the people
that don't like it
"unicorns."
‐I‐I find it too sweet.
You just have to know
that people love it,
even if you don't like it.
It's got money behind it.
We make a scoop
for 68 cents,
and we sell it for $6.
So the ‐‐ the direct margin
on this product...
‐Wow! [ Laughs ]
‐...is incredible.
Oh, my gosh.
I feel, like,
ashamed to say that
for customers watching...
‐Wow.
...but it's pretty awesome.
We're really cultivating
an experience people are
willing to pay for and ‐‐
And where ‐‐ where's the value
at $4.5 million?
T‐Talk to me a little
about that.
Yeah.
S‐So I did this valuation
not even including
the Vegas operations ‐‐
just growth of
our own pier store,
growth of local wholesale,
and that's gonna get us
to $2.25 million
next year in revenue.
‐In revenue, right?
In revenue, correct.
And what do you think
you'll make on that?
I mean, we've
been moving, uh,
with this 27% to 35%
net income ratio.
I don't think I've ever met
a more sophisticated...
‐Yeah.
‐...store owner in my life.
‐Wow.
10 years at Intel
will do that to you, man.
I've, uh, watched
some amazing leaders
make really difficult
business decisions,
and it's undoubtedly the reason
this has gotten so far,
that and my sobriety.
‐Good for you.
Um, I feel so present
and so focused,
and I just know exactly
where this can go,
and I'm looking
for one of you guys
to help me take it there.
I‐I wish
it was something else.
I can't get there
on the cookie dough, though.
I'm out.
‐I totally understand. Yeah.
I'm probably pretty much
like, uh, Robert.
I'm gonna go out
simply because
I just don't
like cookie dough.
Yeah.
I understand that.
‐It's cute, it's fun.
‐Thanks.
I know that there's
a lot of people
that really
love cookie dough...
‐Yeah.
‐...and you've proved it.
‐Uh‐huh.
‐But it's not something
that is a healthy enough
option for me.
‐Okay. It's ‐‐
‐So I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay.
I totally understand. Yeah.
We are looking into, um,
some snack‐size packaging,
and something
more portion control
where you can have a little,
eat a little bit.
O'Leary: So, Kelsey,
you've proven yourself
as a strong operator.
Clearly, sales justify
what you're doing.
I'm gonna give you the credit of
making $2.25 million next year.
So, you're basically
going to end up
with around $350,000 to
distribute to investors,
giving you about 5 to 6
times free cash flow after tax.
What's the valuation
of you?
About
1.8 million bucks.
The problem with your deal
was valuation.
‐Okay.
‐Nothing wrong with you.
Okay. No, I totally
respect that.
I think a lot of ‐‐
There's so many ways to do
valuations in this world,
and, uh, my ‐‐
‐Yeah, I do the real way.
He says the same shtick
all the time.
‐No worries.
‐We're used to it.
I don't see you
writing a check, Mark.
You forgot
to write the check.
‐Why don't you write the check?
‐Kevin, I wasn't clear.
Are you in or out?
‐Oh. Did I not say?
Okay, Kelsey, so that we don't
have to beat each other up,
I'm out.
‐Yeah. Okay. Thank you so much.
‐But I wish you the best.
‐Well, you have Mark left.
‐Yeah. I'll ‐‐ I'll ‐‐
‐My homey. Texas.
‐Texas, I know. Dallas.
‐Don't let me down.
Look, Kelsey,
what you've done is amazing.
Everything about it says
it's a good investment ‐‐
Yeah, and I need your help.
The stadiums, the arenas, and ‐‐
Literally, the conflict
I have ‐‐
and this is
the honest‐to‐God truth...
Yeah. Yeah.
...the whole
obesity thing, right?
Uh‐huh.
Just getting behind
a product and saying,
"Eat more,
eat more, eat more."
I totally feel that.
Great business.
Congratulations, but...
‐Thank you so much.
‐...I have to go out.
Okay.
I totally respect that.
‐Thanks for coming.
‐You guys were amazing.
I'm, like, so sad I'm not
hugging you right now,
but I'm really excited
for the future,
and I appreciate you guys
taking the time.
‐Thanks, Kelsey.
‐Thank you guys so much.
‐Thank you.
‐Uh‐huh.
♪♪
[ Laughs ] Thank you!
The Sharks made a mistake today,
but they'll be back.
I'm know they're gonna
see us crushing it in Vegas.
They're gonna see us
doing amazing things
with e‐commerce sales,
and, uh, I'm excited
to hear from them one day.
♪♪
Happy anniversary,
"Shark Tank."
This is Johnny Georges
of the tree T‐PEE partnered
with Jean Paul DeJoria.
We want to give
a special thank‐you
to Daymond, Mark, Kevin,
Lori, Barbara, and Robert.
Thank you so much
for changing the world
and America
one entrepreneur at a time.
We love you, "Shark Tank,"
and happy 10th anniversary.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a solution
to an age‐old problem.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm William Moujaes.
I'm Michael Koury.
And I'm Tony Lahood.
We're from
Cleveland, Ohio,
and we're the founders
of Saucemoto.
Today we're here to offer you
a 15% stake
in our company
for $45,000.
Since the advent
of the drive‐through,
we've all been faced with
a horrible decision
when eating
in our cars.
‐What's that, Mike?
‐[ Chuckles ]
Risk fumbling
making a mess
with your dipping sauce
or, heaven forbid,
having to eat
a ketchup‐less fry.
‐[ Groans ]
‐That's disgusting.
‐I know.
We could not stand
for this any longer.
That's why we took fate
into our own hands
and molded from
the clay of the Earth
the Saucemoto Dip Clip...
‐♪ Ahh ♪
‐Wow.
...a condiment holder
designed specifically
for your car.
[ Laughs ]
Saucemoto isn't just
a cup holder for your sauce.
No, it's a purveyor
of freedom.
Its universal clip
attaches to just about
any vehicle's air vent,
and its unique
5‐in‐1 aperture
holds sauce from just about
all fast‐food restaurants.
‐Oh!
‐Bravo! Bravo!
Lahood: Through extensive
field testing
and countless nights
of grueling fast‐food research,
we developed Saucemoto
to hold up
to just about
any road condition.
Sharks,
don't try this at home.
‐You want to go for a ride?
‐Yes. I'm starving.
Let's say you're enjoying
your nuggets
when the driver suddenly turns
onto a cobblestone path...
[ Groans ]
[ Rattling ]
...and suddenly
a strong gust of wind
comes from the east.
[ Louder ] It's hardly
ideal dipping conditions.
But not
with Saucemoto.
[ Exhales sharply ]
‐That's right ‐‐
any sauce, any climate,
Saucemoto has
your nuggets covered.
Together,
we could make...
[ Laughter ]
...the ketchup‐less fry
a thing of the past.
It's time to practice
safe sauce.
Lahood: So, Sharks, who wants
to dip into this investment
and make sure
no one has to endure
a sauce‐less
nugget again.
Who's hungry?
‐Yeah.
‐Oh, yeah.
‐Barbara.
‐And a vent, too.
‐Yes.
‐Oh, thank you.
‐More food, just what I needed.
‐Just so you can see that.
‐I have a question.
‐These nuggets are great.
Yeah, these nuggets
are really great.
So, how did you
come up with this?
About 10 years ago,
we were on a road trip,
got hungry, dedicated to get
some nuggets and fries,
and the inevitable
happened,
and I spilled some sauce
in Tony's brand‐new car.
And that's when we just
started brainstorming.
"Okay, h‐how can we
keep 'em secure,
you know, in the car?"
And ‐‐
You really thought
this was a big problem?
‐[ Scoffs ]
‐It really is.
‐It really is a problem.
‐It is for ketchup.
How many of these
have you sold?
‐Uh, we've done 12,000 units...
‐12,000.
...for about
$77,000 in sales.
Wow.
I'm just curious ‐‐
are you excited
to be here?
I'm not sure I'm feeling
any pulse from you.
No, I really am excited
to be here. I mean...
[ Laughter ]
...we worked
really hard on this.
This is
Tony's natural voice.
Greiner: He's just kind of
a chill, mellow guy.
What do you each do
for this business?
What do you each do? What is
your role in this business?
Each of
our roles? Okay.
So, yeah,
I'm the engineer.
I designed most of it
here, testing, and whatnot.
You're design,
you're marketing?
Uh, Tony and I ‐‐ Well,
I kind of span between both.
I'll ‐‐ I'll ‐‐
From design and creative.
I'll do
any of the graphic design.
We do everything in‐house.
Most of the product testing,
too, right?
Oh, yeah. Yes.
Oh, yeah.
And who designed
this package?
‐I did it.
‐Fabulous design.
Thank you.
It tells you everything
you want to see,
it doesn't take up
any space.
I even want to have one, and
I don't even eat any fast food.
That's the reaction
we usually get, is
when people see it,
they're just like,
"Take my money."
So, what does it cost?
What did you sell them for?
We're selling them
for about $5.75 on,
you know,
our website and online.
Uh, it costs us
about 80 cents to make.
What's your background?
I'm a sales engineer
in the tire industry.
I'm a mechanical engineer
doing product development
for a wood tool company.
‐I own a couple of bars.
‐Oh, you do? Good for you.
In Cleveland?
‐Yeah.
I've probably
been there.
Mike, how are people
gonna find you?
We knew that nugget culture
is actually really real ‐‐
‐There's a nugget culture?
‐Absolutely.
We built this
for virality.
We did,
uh, a‐amazing videos,
and those just went viral.
We had 44 million views...
‐How many did you sell?
...over ‐‐ over Facebook.
Do you guys really
expect to sell,
like,
millions of these?
Lahood: A Stanford study
concluded that there's ‐‐
20% of American meals
are actually consumed
in automobiles.
‐Wow.
‐I eat probably 30% of mine.
‐Do you really?
‐Yeah.
Yeah, there's a lot of people
who just don't have time,
like, to go home, sit down ‐‐
‐But how do we get to them?
So, one of the biggest things
that we've realized
with Saucemoto is
it's an extremely good
promotional tool
for companies.
Greiner: Yes.
So if we approach
a fast‐food chain,
rental car companies ‐‐
Um, we are actually
in talks with two major...
Sauce m‐‐
...sauce manufacturers
right now,
um, for
promotional product.
O'Leary:
I think you guys are taking this
the wrong direction.
It's not nuggets.
It's all about the fries.
Everybody eats fries.
I like the deal
'cause I can see
taking it public
on the NYSE.
[ Laughter ]
They'll be ringing
the bell with me.
I think this is huge.
‐Hey, Tony ‐‐
‐Wait a sec, Barb.
Maybe there's a smoking‐hot
offer coming here.
I do see the use of it.
I mean, I eat fries in the car,
and I like to dip my fries,
and it's an issue.
But, you know,
I've got to wet my beak.
I got to wet my beak.
You want a lot of money here.
This is $45,000.
We're not messing around.
15% ‐‐ this imputes a crazy
valuation. You know that.
But I'm willing to go, but I
want a little bit more equity.
I'll do it for 50%.
‐Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Kevin.
‐Thank you.
‐We appreciate that offer.
You want to be at the drive‐up
window, and they say,
"Look, for
an extra whatever,
you can get
the Saucemoto.
This is really cool.
You clip your sauce into it."
That's where
you want to be.
‐They're not gonna sell it.
‐It's a complicated deal ‐‐
Herjavec: And they got
their logo on it.
That's a complicated
deal to cut,
but thank goodness
you've met me,
'cause that's the kind of deal I
like to take on as a challenge.
Ooh.
Cuban: Look, I think
it's a great product,
but, like you've already
found out,
you're gonna have to hustle
for big sales across...
Yeah.
...you know, promotional
opportunities.
That ‐‐ That's just
a lot of time,
and it just doesn't get me
all sauced up,
and so for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
Corcoran: It's such
a little product.
It's such
a small price ‐‐
O'Leary: Don't let
these Sharks drop out.
‐And ‐‐ No, no. And three ‐‐
‐My price is going way up
if these guys drop out.
‐Shut up a minute.
It's going way up
through the roof.
Three grown men
sharing a potential profit
of this tiny, little product.
This isn't
my kind of business.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Herjavec: I have
one final question.
Who created the videos
that's, uh, 44 million hits?
We wrote the scripts, and
we hired a crew to film them.
How much did it cost you
to make however many videos
you made for 44 million views?
‐$4,000?
‐Yeah, $4,000.
‐Wow.
‐You got to be kidding me.
$4,000. You are
in the wrong business.
Am I getting
all of the products
you guys create
going forward?
Lahood: Going forward,
absolutely. Yes.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I get the dream team.
‐That's what you're getting.
‐Yes. Of course.
You'd complete
the dream team.
Okay, guys, I'm gonna
help you out here, okay?
'Cause that's the kind
of guy I am.
I'll give you
$45,000 for 40%.
I got to tell you,
it's the team.
Maybe it works,
maybe it doesn't.
I love the three
of you guys
and your ability to create
the videos and the marketing.
I actually think there's
a great product within you.
‐And this isn't it?
‐This may or may not be it,
but I'll go along
for the ride.
So I'll tell you
what I'm willing to do.
You basically got a third,
a third, a third.
If I come in as a partner,
a very important one
that's willing to work
hard on this,
I'll do it
if I get 25%
so that
we're all equal.
Stop thinking about it,
because the clock is ticking,
and I want you out of here
with me as your partner.
Cuban: He actually would not
be a bad partner for you,
and you knew you were gonna
have to give up 25%.
Yes or no?
♪♪
Guys?
‐We got a deal.
‐Good.
‐Wow.
We are going to take over
the world with this, guys.
‐We're really excited.
‐Thank you, man.
Hug it out, hug it out.
We're talking with ketchup.
We got all the sauces.
‐[ Laughs ] Mustard.
‐Mike, you're the man.
Koury:
Thank you very much.
Now let's go make
hundreds of dollars.
‐All right.
‐[ Laughs ]
Good luck.
Congratulations, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
See you, guys.
Moujaes: Saucemoto's gonna take
off from here, and that's ‐‐
we know Kevin's gonna
open some doors for us.
Now everyone
can practice safe sauce.
That's right.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an elegant version
of a workplace trend.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Mike Bolos.
And my name
is Jason Grohowski.
We're from Chicago, Illinois,
and our company is DeskView.
We're here
seeking $150,000
for 7.5% equity.
Sharks, we are living
in the age of glass.
New buildings, both
residential and commercial ‐‐
they're all glass.
Those drywall conference rooms
are now glass fishbowls.
Closed‐off office spaces
are now open‐concept layouts.
With all this glass,
where do you work?
You can sit at
your standard desk,
hunched over
like a Neanderthal,
or you can create your own
personal standing desk
and have the best view
in the office with...
Both: DeskView.
In the office, DeskView
works great on external
and internal
glass walls,
freeing you
from your desk.
At home, DeskView's the ultimate
minimalist standing desk.
You can move DeskView
to wherever you want to work ‐‐
in the office
or at home.
Want to eat breakfast
while watching the sunrise?
Use a DeskView.
[ Herjavec laughs ]
Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
To uninstall,
simply pull the levers
and DeskView
comes off.
Look, Sharks! No marks!
The install
is just as easy.
♪♪
Bolos: DeskView
is overengineered,
made with aerospace‐grade
aluminum housings
and industrial‐grade
suction discs.
DeskView is safe on glass,
can stay on for years
on a single install,
and hold more weight
than you'd ever need.
Want to prove it?
Sure.
Don't try this
at home.
We are
trained professionals.
‐Oh, my God.
‐On glass? Really? Wow.
‐Wow.
‐We want your help
to bring DeskView to every
window around the world.
So who wants to come up
and try it for themselves?
Who wants
to help me down?
[ Laughs ]
Can it go anywhere
that's not glass?
So, we have
a couple photos.
DeskView works like
melamine top surfaces, tile.
‐So it works on a steel case ‐‐
‐Smooth and nonporous surface.
Herjavec: Oh, you can use it
in the bathroom.
Exactly. So that's
one of the uses ‐‐
Greiner: Marble.
Oh, okay.
So it's not just glass.
Smooth and
nonporous surfaces ‐‐
It works on
metal surfaces.
And how does it
actually attach?
It's suction force.
So what we did is
we took the strongest suction
discs in the industry
and then we re‐created
and built the housings for it
and built some new mechanisms
around it.
What do you sell them
for and what does it
cost to make them?
Yeah, and how many
have you sold?
The white and the Bamboo,
those are our Minimalist
and our Natural.
They retail for $235.
Our ‐‐
‐$235?
Yes. And our clear
Baller retails for $265.
‐And what are your costs?
‐And how many have you sold?
‐We've sold 800 to date.
‐800,000?
800 units.
In how many years?
We just received our inventory
in April of 2018.
You didn't mention what you ‐‐
what they cost to make.
Yes. So, our costs are currently
$80 landed for the units,
but I've been on
an absolute binge
reducing our costs over
the last couple of months,
and I have them down
to about 25% to 30%.
Well, you have great margins ‐‐
$80 versus $235.
Greiner: Yeah, why are you
doing such a high margin?
'Cause you don't need to,
and, you know,
for a desk
like this, it ‐‐
it seems pretty
expensive, right?
Grohowski: This is actually one
of the lowest‐priced desks
that you can get
in an office environment.
That's true.
So when we talk
to people in offices,
they're actually blown away
about how inexpensive it is
compared
to everything else.
Yours is $235.
What's a typical stand‐up desk?
I just don't know what it is.
I mean, your typical
full standing desk
can range from $500
anywhere up to $2,000.
So, there aren't
cheap models out there?
We're kind of that add‐on
into your office ‐‐
or especially in the apartment,
your studio apartment.
We're kind of the only option
for a standing desk.
So, Mike, you've sold about
$70,000 altogether,
$80,000.
‐We're at about $162,000.
This month,
we'll close $100,000.
And that was all
on your own website.
Oh, this month,
you're gonna do $100,000?
‐We're gonna do $100,000.
‐What happened?
So we started marketing
in the direct‐to‐consumer space,
but strictly
on our website.
What we started noticing
is companies
were buying
dozens of units.
So at that time,
we realized,
"Okay, let's, um, focus
on the B2B market."
There was a big large
furniture expo in Chicago.
We didn't have $10,000
to throw out for a booth,
so we got scrappy and
we put up four DeskViews
on the side
of a coffee shop.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
And so that was
in the main thoroughfare.
There were people coming out
of the coffee shop,
and they knew
exactly what to do.
They were using it,
as you can see.
Greiner:
It makes them stand there.
Tell us about you guys.
How did you come up with this?
I, uh, got my B. S.
with studies
at Cornell, Harvard,
and Oxford
and then went on
and got my JD/MBA
at the University
of Pennsylvania.
Went on, practiced three years
in commercial litigation
and then three years
in corporate transactional law.
I got put
inside an office
that I just couldn't put
a standing desk in.
I actually went to the doctor,
and my doctor said,
"Mike, you have tendonitis
everywhere from the hip down."
It was from sitting down.
I mean, we're ‐‐
we're cranking 80‐,
100‐hour‐plus weeks regularly,
and I was just
stuck sitting.
But I had these
floor‐to‐ceiling windows
'cause we were
in a downtown office.
I was like,
"That's perfect."
So I started
building, tinkering.
I did the first 18 prototypes
with $200 in cash.
‐Good for you.
‐So there was some demand,
especially
in my office.
Everyone's like, "What is that?
Where did you get that?"
Started selling those
a little bit,
and it was actually about
time that I met Jason.
Yeah. So, uh, we met
through a mutual friend,
and he showed me
the initial prototype of this,
and immediately
it clicked in my head,
because I spent the past six
years working with companies
talking to executives.
"We want standing desks.
Our employees are demanding
them, but they're so expensive."
You're a furniture guy,
Jason?
Uh, commercial
real estate broker.
I don't know
if I see it as a desk.
The surface area
is just too small.
Well, one second.
I'll actually show you
another one that ‐‐
Bolos: 'Cause I never stop
working on innovation.
But over time,
the square foot per employee
in company offices has gone
from 250 square feet
down to 120.
‐I don't disagree with you.
That's why people
want to stand.
So, this guy,
I call the Big Baller.
Um...
‐The Big Baller.
14 inches deep.
Yeah. So, we added
a couple more inches
for those that
have larger laptops.
What price
is that gonna be?
We're gonna
price that $275.
Corcoran: Can I speak from
a perspective of an employer?
When I built my offices,
I was meticulous
about the design
and hated it
when my salespeople
even put their kids in frames
on their desk shelves.
It just messed
the whole place up.
You spend tons of money, you
want gorgeous corporate office,
and then people start
bringing their tchotchke.
I hated it.
To a corporate client, B2B,
which is your specific model,
you want someone
to buy 50 of them.
Could you imagine 50 of these
along the plate‐glass windows
of an office building
in Midtown Manhattan?
‐It's terrible.
‐Good point.
I see it as a consumer,
individual‐sale market.
I really do.
So I don't believe, frankly,
in any of the directions
you're going in,
so I'll have
to graciously step out.
I think it's a beautifully
designed product.
You've obviously put
an incredible amount
of work on it.
It's so sturdy.
But, you know,
I'm kind of sitting here, and
I wouldn't use it as a desk.
I can't get there. I'm out.
‐Thank you.
I mean, I can see it
as a complement ‐‐ I mean,
you know, to my desk
or in my office
or if someone's coming in
from the outside ‐‐
keep two of them
in the closet
and setting them up
where you need it.
But, you know,
I agree with Barb
that I see these more
in the home.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
‐Okay. Thank you.
‐Thank you.
I prefer this selling
directly to consumers online.
The margins
are pretty good.
I don't mind exploring
the, um...
the whole thing, B2B.
But you're gonna find out
how tough that is,
and it just ‐‐
it just sucks cash.
Look,
I'll make you an offer.
‐Wow.
I'll give you the $150,000.
I want 15%.
Thank you
for the offer.
I don't see it
as a permanent desk
for somebody
using it all day long.
But I thought it was
really interesting,
I actually think,
for commercial space.
Like, you know,
there's never enough room
at a Starbucks
or this or that.
I thought
that was really smart.
But I don't like
your price point.
I've done a lot of products
over the years,
and the one thing I know
is things that soar,
things that
really do great,
are things that are a good idea
that people like,
but if you can give it to them
at an affordable price,
if they're
on the fence at all,
they're gonna buy it.
I respect the margin that
you feel you want to make.
The big question is,
is really how low can it go?
So, with what
I've been able to do
over the past
couple of months,
plus the volume‐based
discounts,
we should be at around
$45 landed, $46 landed.
So you can
cut it in half.
‐Yeah.
‐Yes.
All right, I'm gonna give you
a really Shark‐y offer.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Kevin has offered $150,000
for 15%
of Jason and Mike's
mountable stand‐up
desk company, DeskView.
But Lori
is also interested.
All right, I'm gonna give you
a really Shark‐y offer.
I would want to be...
a third partner.
‐Oh.
‐33%.
‐♪ Dun‐dun, dun‐dun, dun‐dun ♪
‐$150,000 for 33.3%.
‐Ouch.
‐Because I feel like
we'd have to go to a million
factories and cost this out
where it could be something
where we'll sell
hundreds of thousands
of units, not thousands.
There's blood
in the water now, Mike.
Bolos: Well, yeah,
and with our ‐‐
With the projections
of these, you know,
multi‐billion‐dollar
distributors
that we're talking to,
I mean, they're saying
they'll move 900 units
a month next year.
They're salespeople.
They tell you
what you want to hear.
‐But here's the difference ‐‐
Greiner: I don't want them
moving 900.
I want them
moving 90,000.
So you guys know,
the more I think about this,
the more I listen to Lori,
I'm modifying my offer.
I'm going up to 20%.
‐[ Laughs ]
I'll give you the, uh,
$150,000 for 20%.
This isn't,
uh, gonna be easy,
'cause I think
it's got to be 99 bucks.
I'm willing to take a flier ‐‐
$150,000, 20%.
You can do Lori's deal
for $150,000 for 33.3%.
You guys have
to make a decision.
♪♪
Lori,
would you do 20%?
♪♪
But you want me
to put the value add ‐‐
I mean, I know it's gonna be
some heavy lifting from my end.
I know that,
because I've done it,
again and again and again.
♪♪
Kevin, we'll take
your offer for 20%.
[ Claps ]
‐Wow.
‐Wow. Surprising.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐You were the only one left.
I can help you
quite a bit, actually.
‐We're excited.
‐Yeah.
‐Wow. That surprised me.
‐That really surprised me.
Why would they want to do
business with Kevin?
You're
the perfect partner.
Well, 'cause she wanted
the one‐third.
‐I wanted a third.
‐Congratulations.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Thank you.
You could have
had Kevin at 15%.
‐These are the gambles we take.
‐Thank you, Lori.
‐You're welcome.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Thank you for all your time.
‐Congrats, guys.
Bolos: It's amazing. I mean,
Kevin ‐‐ he's gonna blow it up.
You know, even in
the brief talk that we had,
we know that
he has the ideas,
he has the understanding
of the distribution model,
and we're just gonna kill it
with Kevin as a partner.
♪♪